What how I met your mother means to me is that grief is temporary whether I've had a fantastic day or a terrible day watching that show is always the right move for the mood.
我如何认识你母亲对我来说意味着悲伤是暂时的，无论我度过了美好的一天还是糟糕的一天，观看该节目总是适合心情的举动。
And there was this wonderful show.
于是就有了这场精彩的表演。
That was all about how the randomness of life is what gets you exactly where you need to be.
这就是关于生活的随机性如何让你准确地到达你需要的地方。
Welcome to how we made your mother, which I think we're calling.
欢迎来到我们如何创造你的母亲，我想我们正在称呼她。
This is our new podcast rewatching 208 episodes of how I met your mother.
这是我们的新播客，重播 208 集《我是如何遇见你母亲》的。
I'm Josh Radner.
我是乔什·拉德纳。
and I played Ted Mosby on the show for nine seasons.
我在剧中扮演泰德·莫斯比九季。
And I am thrilled to be joined by Craig Thomas who co-created the show along with Carter Bayes.
我很高兴克雷格·托马斯 (Craig Thomas) 加入，他与卡特·贝叶斯 (Carter Bayes) 共同创作了该剧。
Josh, somehow it has been 20 years since our show premiered.
乔希，不知怎的，我们的节目首播已经过去 20 年了。
That can't be right, your math is off.
这不可能是对的，你的数学不行。
It seems wrong, I'm sure it's wrong, let's check it, but it's also been 10 years since the show went off the air and while deeply disturbing, it makes it a good time to look back.
这似乎是错的，我确信是错的，让我们检查一下，但距离该节目停播也已经过去了 10 年，虽然令人深感不安，但现在正是回顾的好时机。
Well, if you're a super fan, we're gonna get into all the secrets, theories, easter eggs, slash pineapples, and general knowledge.
好吧，如果您是超级粉丝，我们将探讨所有秘密、理论、复活节彩蛋、切菠萝和常识。
General knowledge?
常识？
But we'll also use him-yim and our relationship to it, these 20 years later, to talk about life and love and art and everything in between.
但二十年后，我们也会用他和我们之间的关系来谈论生活、爱情、艺术以及介于两者之间的一切。
And just like the show itself, this podcast doesn't exist without you.
就像节目本身一样，没有您就没有这个播客。
Your voices will be a big part of what we do.
您的声音将成为我们工作的重要组成部分。
I'm alone, and I won't be soon in New York City.
我独自一人，而且我不会很快到达纽约市。
Tell the people listening.
告诉正在听的人。
How many times over has your wife, Tornana, seen how I met your mother?
你的妻子托尔纳娜看过多少次我是如何遇见你母亲的？
It is zero times.
是零次。
But we have a section called questions and observations from a clinical psychologist, relationship expert, who's never seen how I met your mother, who also happens to be very Josh.
但是我们有一个叫做问题和观察的部分，来自一位临床心理学家、关系专家，他从来没有见过我是如何认识你母亲的，而她恰好也是一个非常乔希的人。
Is that title too catchy?
这标题是不是太吸引人了？
We are now embarking on this rewatch together, our her first watch rather.
我们现在正在一起重新观看，这是我们的第一部观看。
A couple of times when I was looking at Robin in a certain way, she would go, I know that look.
有几次，当我以某种方式看着罗宾时，她会说，我知道那种表情。
I'm gonna see you, please permit me to tell you everything in New York City.
我要去见你，请允许我告诉你纽约市的一切。
But there's one guy owned the bar, he had never been off the island of Mallorca.
但这家酒吧的老板是一个人，他从未离开过马略卡岛。
He said, How I met your mother has taught me that what's happening now will be my memories one day.
他说，我是如何认识你母亲的，这告诉我，现在发生的事情有一天会成为我的回忆。
So make sure that you're making good memories for yourself in the present moment.
因此，请确保您此刻正在为自己留下美好的回忆。
And this old man, he must admit he fell in love with you in New York City.
而这个老人，他必须承认他在纽约爱上了你。
I'm excited to unpack this stuff, and it feels honestly, it feels like psychologically healthy for me to do this, you know, it feels like are you ready to go back to the Titanic?
我很高兴能打开这些东西，老实说，这样做对我来说心理上是健康的，你知道，感觉就像你准备好回到泰坦尼克号了吗？
We're marrying March 10th.
我们3月10日结婚。
Learn more at HowWeMajormother.com
了解更多信息，请访问 HowWeMajormother.com